now Kris Kobach is the Kansas secretary
of state he joins us now Kris you are a
man you know of you've been working on
this for quite some time for years you
know what the situation is this is not
unfamiliar to you either can you give us
a sense really as people might want to
blame the the shutdown but this is
really chaos that is unfolding and an
overwhelmed Customs and Border
Protection Force overwhelmed ice perhaps
because they're contained if you will by
certain Court decisions about what they
can and cannot do what do you think is
going on in El Paso now and should the
people there be concerned about what's
happening well first of all you're
correct when you suggest this is not
because of the government shutdown
enforcement and removal operations of
ice that's the division that handles
this type of duty they're essential
employees they're working at full steam
regardless of the shutdown there might
be some frank Affairs officers who
normally you know contact the press and
things like that who might not be
working but it's not because by the
shutdown secondly although the numbers
this week in El Paso are large and
larger than normal people should be
aware that there are if you look
nationally you know thousands of people
being released into the United States
who are asylum seekers not necessarily
worthy of asylum but claiming that they
are every month and so this is a big
problem here this this number should
shock you in the last five years the
number of asylum claims in the United
States system has gone up 2,000 percent
there are almost 800,000 asylum cases
pending in our immigration courts and
the vast majority of those are not
legitimate it's estimated that these
Central American claims well over 90
percent are going to be denied they're
not even close to being a legitimate
claim asylum asylum requires that your
government back home is persecuting you
and you have a well-founded fear of
being hurt because of your membership in
a particular social group whereas many
people are coming in saying well I've
got gangs in my neighborhood and so the
this Asylum loophole has become a
massive loophole that is causing a huge
problem for the whole system it is a big
problem this is just a symptom and we
were letting these people out of course
it presuming they'll come back this is
the old game to get their court hearing
and then they just never show up but we
also learn
and a couple weeks ago from secretary
Neilson of department of homeland
security that we have an arrangement
with Mexico now that they would hold
people who are looking for asylum and
until we can adjudicate them do you
think that's really going to happen or
do you think that we're still having is
the president still going to have to go
and try to get this done through the
courts which clearly seem to be
resistant to him being able to control
the border well a little of both so I
think that what secretary Nielsen
announced last week is a big first it's
not a first step it's a big step in that
direction for those people who haven't
yet crossed into the United States but
most the people were talking about here
in El Paso they were already in the
United States when they were apprehended
many of them anyway right and for those
people what DHS needs to do right away
is to finalize a proposed regulation
that they promulgated back in September
and that regulation will override what's
called a Flores settlement which is why
we're releasing all these people and
allow the detention of complete family
units together until their case is
adjudicated fires and we got to get that
right away and there's no time to waste
yeah because that's that's the question
what what do we do next and that's a
great point thank you sir for joining us
I appreciate it have a great night